let's bring this ridiculous conversation
back to the war and stuff like that well
what happened was yeah basically biden
we're against blinkford came out and he
said contrary to what i want to say
before was uh i'd like to make the
announcement the united states
government is going to the moon yeah
exact thing he said spreading fun is now
going to be illegal a crime punishable
by death
joe biden came out and said the united
states will be canceling its blink blink
fitness membership cancelling the blink
fitness membership and we will be uh
uh tying american coin it's gonna be
tethered one to one to doge is there has
anyone looked into the possibility that
this whole putin ukraine thing is just
because he had a gym membership in
ukraine yeah
he could just walk he knows i can't
cancel he goes you know what well i'm
gonna go in there and i'm going to
cancel it myself he shows up and he goes
to biden in a meeting and he's like you
know look everything's great we're fine
with the sanctions we're going to work
it out i know we can negotiate
shakespeare
one quick thing i got this
it's it's an american company and
joe's just like you're familiar with
blink fitness but joe's like oh dude you
signed a contract man you got to pay and
putin's like dude i don't go there
anymore and biden's just like bro
you signed the contract
what if you need a shower next time
you're here it's good
and then such like and then all of a
sudden bombs are dropping yeah no but uh
in terms of the war stuff like you will
own nothing and you'll be happy they're
talking to us about eating bugs for the
longest time they're talking to us about
living in the pods then they're you know
they're telling everyone to stay home
and work remote and then as soon as the
covet thing like disappears
all of a sudden now it's war with you
war with russia and ukraine and it's
it's like the same prescription gas
prices are through the roof it's it's
like this the same issues are starting
to occur they just found and and
the same things are happening whether
it's like hey we have a new reason that
we can just print money and then
distribute it as we please
yeah they haven't they haven't quite
turned on that spigot yet but that's
probably yeah i mean they just announced
14 billion to ukraine or something like
that yeah that's great or whatever i'm
just saying they have you're just saying
they haven't no they're not like the
trail the coveted trillions like the 4
trillion or whatever i mean that press
is is still hot
this is the crazy thing this is why you
know i've been saying i'm trying to buy
as much as i can for the studio and the
company instead of waiting so we bought
like five desktops we need them and
they're just like they're cheapos
they're small like you you can type on
them you can't really do anything like
you can barely watch a movie on them a
couple hundred bucks with you with a
monitor and i'm just like we need them
for the office we need them for you know
writers just buy them all now because
i'm gonna wait and it's gonna go up 50
bucks it's going to go up 100 bucks i
mean especially anything that has any
kind of chip in it
oh yeah dude we're gonna lose taiwan in
two seconds i don't know about that i i
thought for sure i'd given up but now
seeing all these sanctions on russia i
think that the ccp is more about profit
i don't think they're really gonna throw
all this
yeah they're not gonna shut off the west
like that i just think it's the raw
materials i don't i don't mean china's
gonna
uh stop providing chips i think it's
just gonna be like we're not gonna have
the materials you know i'm a big booty
judge fan so yeah so when he came out
and said you should buy electric car i
was like that's good points i bought
like seven of them just to make sure
because you know i i don't understand
why poor people don't just do that you
know they just just buy a couple
electric cars you have to worry about
gas prices ever again you have to think
about it bro yeah you've got to think
about it just buy an electric car and
you can just drive it the funny thing is
you know the quite you ask the question
of these people where does the
electricity come from
it's like fossil fuels
it doesn't come from this well did you
see i don't know if you saw the alberta
guy from canada because they were
basically when when all this stuff
happened they were like okay we need to
you know find more oil we're going to
meet with saudi arabia or whatever and
the alberta guy was like yeah happy to
meet you we could sort this whole thing
up pretty easy you just have to open up
our pipeline again
yeah that's pretty funny you guys ever
go to the keystone usdclock.org
and just there's like a
in time you know what's not our union
squad in union square in new york i
always thought it was the debt clock but
it turns out it was actually a regular
it was actually my my d size yeah yeah
it goes down you know it goes down danny
thought it was the us dead it turns out
it was his mom's scale
but you know the number is going down is
it oh yeah what of the debt so the
number in union square in new york no
it's a clock with this it's a date and
time but the back of the the second
number is the amount of time left
yes exactly so if you're looking at the
number you're seeing the digits on the
right
going down so if your d size your d is
getting smaller
good news for my pants because
because it's like easy budget two clocks
puts it at like a billion feet that
actually is good news from the
band
now you can breathe no i just i i we
keep hearing the good news from my back
so here's what i did i bought a bunch of
emergency food and i didn't do it
because i think we're going to need to
eat it i didn't do it because i thought
the apocalypse was going to happen i did
it because i thought it was going to
become more expensive in a few months
and i'm like if this stuff lasts 30
years some of it does and then i'm just
like
why didn't you buy the 30 year old stuff
no it's just to see what it tastes like
buying 30 years of food like is there a
way that you can no no no no no no no
it's not it's not 30 years it's food
that lasts a shelf life of 30 years no
but that's what i mean no i'm saying you
buying food where you're like you bought
too much food it's like yeah well if we
have to eat it in 2055 we'll eat it in
2015
well because look look
we've got you know around 30 employees
which are you gonna eat on that in the
next 40 years yeah
uh within the next 30 years is there a
possibility that there's a storm is
there a flood is there a blizzard is
there a well sure but i'm thinking about
it more practically like sometimes it
rains and their floods and you know we
got the river right there you'll be the
only guy everyone's eating their bug
burgers and you're gonna have all your
30 years of supply he's gonna have his
space food that's a thing unfortunately
not it's a bucket that lasts 30 years
it's a it's like a day's worth of food i
have a question did they forget so the
expiration date it's free it's like
dried in a package yeah you can put it
in a bucket for 30 years
but it's like one day of food yeah yeah
i got it yeah you said you said 30 years
of the food or something no no i'm like
no we've got like two weeks worth is is
is there well how much did you buy
enough for like two weeks worth of food
but my point is oh i thought you i don't
think i don't think in the next few
years i'm gonna eat it i'm like i just
think the next few years is gonna double
in price
well right now i guess it's food you're
worried you see your portfolio you're
like what's your important folio i got
some of the s p 500 a bunch of nutri
grain bars
the hard coffee the pie chart is actual
bunker pie why don't you go look at our
storeroom we we've got maybe like a
thousand gatorades yeah a lot of stories
you have a lot of swords yeah that's
what you want what you really have the
tim cuz much is 50 swords we should we
should probably actually film it because
it's funny be like we need to think and
prepare ahead which we get swords swords
or blades yeah they're all we're all
training that really is what you want
i did buy a bunch of swords that's going
to be you just like eating uh opening up
and divvying up the bunker food with the
sword
all right
got everybody this this behind me is a
wakazashi it's not a sharpened blade but
it is a sharpened point because it's
more like decorative but it is real but
it's more for poking you could poke okay
but uh but for the most part it's meant
to just be like art it's like i think
it's like a it's like a laminated blade
or something i don't know maybe it's not
right but it's not supposed to rust away
yeah and it was like oh that's for sure
it was it's actually i was it it was
nice people were complaining with them
all you got a sword and axe
there you go but people are complaining
about my mall sword because i went to
the mall oh you bought one from a mall
yeah it's like just cheap steel right
cost 10 bucks and everyone's making
ex-girlfriend's name engraved in it yeah
that's some anime on it and i'm just
like why are you guys ragging on my
mouseword i know it's a mall sword fine
so i bought an actual wakazashi from a
company that makes them and i was like
just unsharpened because you know we
don't actually need to go around but
then i thought about it and i was like
i'm gonna buy a bunch of actual swords
yeah so i bought swords i'm like you
know here's what i'm thinking gonna get
more expensive might buy it now huh i
mean the the raw materials in them
definitely will be
yeah the steel and whatnot yeah man iron
and that's better if you have to use
them against someone who and and who
knows how to use this in the springtime
those weeds man they grow quick dude
whacking weeds with a sword in your
underwear yeah it's more important just
let the neighbors know who's boss also
the system you're out you can see the
muscles deep july just whacking your
weeds with a sword wearing long johns no
shirt
the sweat flies
i got a titanium sealed
you know uh katana and we're gonna go
out and we're gonna we're gonna do the
lawn we're gonna we're gonna you know
swipe the grass titanium
yeah that doesn't metal
yeah and you're you know you gotta you
wanna get the grass the right height
yeah no to be completely honest that'll
keep people from swatting you again too
when they do that right
uh
this this like i bought some swords and
uh we the the food stuff although i'm
serious because it's like
if we've we've eaten a ton of it already
and that's the thing it's like it's food
you just eat it it's mac and cheese it's
mac and cheese it's like crafts and then
you're sort of dipping into your
investments though never get high you
don't supply
25 you're dipping into the flour
you're breaking one of the crackers i
don't know if you bought you actually no
this is actually true i did we should
get a thousand times more than we think
we need
because they're not expensive no it's
just in case now the funny thing is
smash glass if it does you know go to
like nuclear war with putin or whatever
where people are gonna watch this and
they're to watch it laughing at us
like eve
they're going to be trying to find out
the address of this place so they can
get some of it
they have everything we need because on
the one hand it's like okay let's buy
this compound and build this thing it's
like okay that's investment one
investment two is like a bucket of slop
hey this is good food
pancake mix
can you find out like do you know what
the price of uh a good example would be
around y2k because that was what 22
years ago i'm sure they were selling
these things i wonder how much they've
gone up since then and then it would be
interesting to eat one of those because
i'd be 22 years old how old are how old
are you guys i'm 38. you're age you're
36
so uh is it just me or
did everybody
on y2k turn the power off at their house
on new year's no we did not you didn't
we just played magic you guys didn't do
that uh i wasn't i'm like magic
i was not a friend my friend's house
they turned the power off
i don't know
everyone was like
it's 1207. oh you did that as a gag i
didn't do it someone did the party oh i
always think someone did that you're
right someone was doing that in every
house across yeah every every dad joke i
did the breaker
playing magic i just wasn't i was sick
that night yeah oh don't know stressed
out you know that's the funniest i
remember i had a girl in a car and a
bridge when it was happening right yeah
that's the way to get it
suck if the world's about to end that's
right think about how insane the fake
news was
like how insane the fake news was about
the media was saying y2k so you know
what we did at my house we we had a
bunch of computers and we went into the
bios and we like set the internal clock
for like a half an hour then we went
into windows we did the same thing see
what happened and we sat back and
literally nothing happened and i was
like this is dumb so nothing's going to
happen yeah and we're like nothing's
going to happen they're making it up i
think they thought that because of the
way computers were reading data it was
going to like cycle to all zeroes and
well like the banks since they were like
all the corporations but they were they
were able to do that
they were making y2k compliant programs
you could buy yeah yeah and then i'm
like it just changed to zero zero and
nothing happens thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you